Madame, qui a donné  le droit de vote aux
femmes  ?
Je sais que c'est en 1945
le 21 octobre, mais je ne pourrai pas vous dire qui
premier chez blum général de gaulle je
dirais pétain peut-être en sauriol mais
pour son sérieux messieurs d'aquarium
crois que je ne suis pas au courant
parce que je porte télévision
dans les années 30 les femmes françaises
sont face à un constat est à une
question
inspiré par les suffragettes anglaise
qui ont milité pour le droit de vote en
grande bretagne dès 1903 les femmes
s'unissent et entreprennent des actions
pour faire entendre leur voix lors des
scrutins
liberté égalité femmes de toutes
conditions unissez vous pour conquérir
votre égalité les militantes féministes
américaines sont très satisfaits de leur
journée de revendications pourtant
parfois mouvementés organisée à
l'occasion du 50e anniversaire du droit
de vote pour les femmes aux états unis
en france un personnage s'est démarqué
pour faire avancer cette cause
les journalistes écrivains conférencière
et ethnologue le but de son existence
aura été de servir de grandes causes la
france la paix mais aussi la pose des
femmes louise weiss a toujours été
curieuse des autres attentive à leurs
joies leurs peines en chine en afrique
ou à paris louise weiss a consacré sa
vie à ses causes avec un militantisme
acharné
ah oui absolument acharné parce que non
seulement je pensais aux droits des
femmes mais je pensais que chez les
femmes entrer dans l'arène politique
l'ambiance générale s'améliorerait dans
le sens de la paix entre les deux
guerres la france se reconstruit et le
rôle des femmes est devenu déterminant
que ce soit dans l'industrie
la fonction publique où les actions
sociales oui nous étions responsables
moment là un mineur pour nos droits
comme nous disions majeur pour nos
fautes interdite est incapable devant la
loi chose aucun droit de la citoyenneté
en 1935 alors que les femmes n'ont ni le
droit de vote ni celui de se présenter
elle va alors bravé les interdictions
pour servir la cause il a bien organisé
en préfecture de votre milieu
à l'aide sans volonté la pluie ayant des
pertes et nouvelle opération
l'écu de bois tenir jusqu'au bout une
urne symbolique l'a33 et pour la
défendre les manier la poudre la poudre
de riz le ton est donné
la presse relaie cet événement est petit
à petit l'idée s'immisce dans la
conscience collective
les femmes ont une voix notamment
électorale et moins de dix ans plus tard
bien mesdames c'est au général de gaulle
que vous devez le droit de vote le 21
avril 1944 en effet réuni sous sa
présidence à alger le comité français de
libération nationale prenait cette
décision après avis favorable de
l'assemblée consultative le général mais
pas uniquement je pense que la politique
féminine qui a été menée a été
importante
donc cette promotion fait avec un
certain retard sur les pays voisins
la france vit alors un jour historique
pour la première fois depuis toujours
ce choeur de 20 millions de voix c'était
le 29 avril 1945 et les bureaux de vote
malgré tout l'appareil solennelle du
tapis père de lise en noir et de l'urne
sont devenus très féminin puisque au
nombre des électeurs s'ajoute pour la
première fois la poule b et lectrices
elle participe alors massivement fier de
faire partie des premières générations à
jouir de cette prérogative
décidément se préparent à apporter du
nouveau du nouveau oui mais pas pour
tout le monde
vous ne votez pas rue pourquoi tu as
raison mais pas merci certaines femmes
et c'est bien leur droit refusent de
voter par habitude ou par désintérêt le
rôle des femmes dans la vie politique
reste à asseoir et même à justifier pour
certains d'accord pour qu'une femme
devienne maire de grimaud
pourquoi pas il manque à l'état si
intelligente y ait trop de raisons
moi non la femme a que ce couple son
ménage et pattaya pour le t4 gold
vous allez mal vous n'êtes pas de temps
être de son temps c'est sans doute ce
qui pose le plus de problèmes à
n'importe quelles avancées sociales je
crois que maintenant du fait de légalité
de leurs droits des femmes nouvelles
sont nés et qu'ils ont à aménager les
conquêtes que nous avons fait pour elle
et qui n'y vont pas lentement aménager
les conquêtes ça veut aussi dire aller
de l'avant et prendre des places pour
arriver à une parité
il n'est même pas impensable d'imaginer
que l'une d'elles un jour sera
présidente de la république et c'est en
1974 pour la première fois qu'une femme
se présente à l'élection eh bien oui je
suis une femme
et j'ose me présenter comme candidate à
la présidence de cette république
d'hommes le message de louise weiss a
ouvert la voie à des droits élémentaires
qui ont profondément changé le paysage
démocratique français avec une idée
aussi forte que simple je crois qu'il
faut retenir se fie au total j'ai voulu
que rien de ce qui est humain ne me soit
étranger